hello everyone I'm so excited to be here
thanks for having me I thought today I'd
start talking about a little bit about
growing a creative company because it
might apply to some of the things you're
doing growing the company a little bit
of backstory on me philosophy and then
getting into some of the tricks of the
trade of design and some lesson learned
along the way I wanted to start with
this image of nests if I were a bird I
think I would be some bird that would
design nest like this I think they're so
amazing they represent really pushing
material to the limit of its structural
integrity they're beautifully designed
for their purpose they create community
and they're made from materials that are
reused recycled and whatever is nearby
so a really creative design for a nest
our i started studio gang really
thinking about how to address some of
these major issues that we're facing
climate change the growth of cities the
loss of biodiversity sometimes due to
that growth of cities and also to
enhance communities in which we live and
as we've developed as a company we
started to really try to seek out
companies organizations that have some
of the same goals and that's when I
really feel like we do our best work so
we've been working trying to help
organizations use design and
architecture to make their future more
potent more more concrete and through
identity and through how architecture
can help serve a company's philosophy
just talking a little bit about one of
the examples of where I think we really
succeeded in doing something like that
this is a small project at the lincoln
park zoo in chicago they had a 19th
century kind of reflecting pond
designed for strolling around built in
1908 and the the pool over time had
become really polluted and not in very
good shape and the zoo came to us and
said we want to improve this property
just make it more aesthetically
appealing and represent who we are a
little bit better so with the problem
like that we really gathered around a
number of experts not just our
structural engineers but also people
that dealt with water quality
hydrologists biologists and and sat down
really early in the process to think
about what this pond could be besides
improving it aesthetically and because
we started so early in the process
together with the client we really
discovered what the potential could be
for this pond so today it's it's
probably in its fourth year of
completion but we really just reimagine
the pond altogether and found out that
it could do many more functions than it
currently was doing so it's it was a
reflecting pool but now just with
deepening the the pond from three feet
to 20 feet we're able to really improve
that water quality something that as an
architect I wouldn't have known about
but something that really allowed it to
become a functioning infrastructure a
stormwater retention pond and improve
the water quality enough that it could
actually be a habitat so fish could
winter over in this place we also took
it off of the city water supply and just
are using this runoff water cleaning it
with plants to go back into the pond and
at the same time creating a place is
really attractive to people and the
animals right in the middle of the city
so this is some of the early ideas of
the structure for a pavilion on the site
that would become a learning pavilion
for for students so a lot of the times
we work with the the
builders of testing materials pushing
them to their limits this is really made
of a sustainable material would bent in
two different directions that's one of
the great things about wood and it's
also embodying all the carbon in it so
we made these prefabricated pieces and
brought them to site to create this
pavilion and now it's really starting to
function incredibly well both for people
who wander around and and stroll through
it at night but also have activities
there and also attracting animals so it
Lincoln Park Zoo is really becoming more
of this zoo without cages where animals
come and voluntarily explain em selves
so they went from having 40 nesting
herons black-crowned night herons here
to 400 pair in those those years so it's
become pretty intense and then it is
also attracting small mammals like these
coyotes of which there are about 2,000
of them now in Chicago that are being
tracked by researchers to see how they
survive in this urban environment so I
think it's really interesting to see how
public space and these kind of habitats
can come into contact and provide a more
rich experience in the city but it's
used for classes like I said people use
the pavilion for yoga a lot of the
architects like to get married there
Madame but also the teaching
opportunities and teaching kids about
ecology or strong it's also been used
for some dance performances and so it's
really become this incredible attractive
very vibrant space in the city and
embodying a lot of the ideas that we've
had after after winning the macarthur
fellowship in 2011 it was almost like I
felt like validated for what we were
doing kind of going on the right
direction because our practice is really
a little bit expanded outside of what a
normal architect does getting into a lot
of these areas and so that fellowship
really helped me kind of like get the
confidence to just keep pushing that as
well so with another organization that
we are helping to
define their future was the ARCA center
for social justice leadership at
Kalamazoo College and they they they had
the problem of not ever there really is
in the building that's a typology for
social justice buildings I mean a lot of
times social justice happens in hidden
places so we recently completed a
building for them that we hope will help
define who they can become it's it's on
this small column in Kalamazoo campus
and made with this chord with masonry so
I'm going to show you a little clip of
how that building looks
in the past social justice and social
justice activism seems like it's always
happened in in visible places with this
project I feel like there's an actual
building something that embodies the
idea of social justice in every way from
it outside to it's inside
you
using wood masonry was a technique that
was incredibly sustainable and so the
idea of reviving that came to us like
would it be possible to actually bring
this technique into the 21st century
Kalamazoo College has a history of
social justice they asked us to think
about what a center like this would be
like so this diagram that we came up
with which is kind of has these three
wings allows us to create intense
transparency in three different
directions it's a different kind of
articles on our site but also allows us
to have pockets of spaces tucked away
different sizes of spaces to have
conversations that might not always be
easy conversations there is this kind of
crossing over pathways that people could
encounter each other even if they didn't
plan to
another element that really reinforces
the social gathering component of the
spaces with the hearth there's a
desperate to have leadership in the
space of social justice action and this
is a place where that's going to happen
so the the results will we will see but
if they have a new home and many of the
things that we did in that building were
very inventive because we've kind of
resuscitated this technique that we
found had been forgotten and brought the
right people together to be able to see
if we could make it work for an
institution where the building has to
actually last 100 years so another thing
I guess for architects if you think back
just what we're what we're doing is
really expanding the definition you know
back in the medieval times the architect
was called a master builder and at that
time the role was really all in one an
architect designer a builder and an
engineer in one person and what we've
seen over time is that that that role
has separated out and becomes a series
of specialists and doing different
things especially through up till the
Industrial Revolution this is Corbusier
but at that time all of these different
design types started spreading and
shifting off and becoming individual so
now we have not only architects but
theatrical designers exhibition
designers we have lighting designers and
then in engineering obviously we have
many different fields mechanical
engineering Electrical Engineering
plumbing engineering and so you would
think that the architect is naturally a
great collaborator because we we
actually have to bring all these things
together just to make a building happen
but in fact that's really the problem it
it tends to be more of a role of
coordination and less about
collaboration so
become really good at maxing out what
collaboration can give you in terms of
design ideas and design input now I
think you know really a 21st century
creative team is is much more diverse it
takes all of us working together in
different teams and that's what we've
become really good at forming those
teams and creating teams and getting the
right people together so one of the
things I think is important is really
just having a diverse group people with
different points of view because with
with architecture unlike product design
every single building is a unique thing
and it will be it's a one-off in a way
so this serial project quality of
architecture requires a special
attention to forming the team and making
it making sure that you get those points
of view in there within in the office as
well there needs to be a kind of a a
very comfortable and open atmosphere
that will allow people to test ideas
anyone can can have an idea from the
person who's of in turn on day one to
somebody who's a architect for the last
you know 50 years so so we try to create
that atmosphere and make it possible so
people feel comfortable seeing their
ideas drawing their ideas and getting
him out there and and it's a spirit
that's really just been cultured in our
office one project I recently worked on
that was a designed for an exhibition
was the moma project moma the museum of
modern art we designed it was kind of a
research study that was shown in the
museum called foreclosed rehousing the
American Dream and we were studying what
happened to these inner-ring suburbs
early suburbs in light of the
foreclosure crisis and so what for that
particular project it wasn't only the
interior team of our office and our
extension our professionals but we
really had to decide who we want to
engage that had special expertise that
we didn't have to address a problem as
serious as foreclosure so we're not just
thinking about the building but we're
also thinking about the economics of the
situation the situation with with
housing public housing and so for that
project I gathered a team that included
in economists a researcher a landscape
architect and urban specialist a housing
activists and and we specifically came
together for this project to try to
understand the foreclosure one of the
things that we noticed when we started
looking at Cicero was that a lot of the
bungalows the little one the
single-family homes had many mailboxes
on them so they were with all these
names so we thought something was going
on with the traditional fabric in the
suburb that wasn't the way it was
designed in the beginning and and it
turns out that it really was a
reflection of what had happened in
Cicero this this entering suburb with
the the transformation of the family
from 20th century family too many more
mixed and individuals living together
extended families unrelated adults that
come to the city to work so it was a
much different makeup than what we
originally thought and so we wanted to
get to the bottom of this and in order
to do that we felt we needed to engage
people that really lived there so in a
very careful and respectful way we found
a way to interact with residents who had
gone through the foreclosure crisis and
got their stories so in a way it was
engaging engaging people that beyond the
professional circle but the real people
who lived in these homes and and one of
the things that was really a discovery
there was that the city of Cicero had
been planning on extending a rail line
to their suburb to
because they thought that that would
solve you know some of the job losses
but what we found out by interviewing
people is really that they were
everybody was working two and three jobs
and moving all over in various places
around the suburbs not going to the city
center and so for our proposal we
recommended a car share as another way
to do a sustainable transportation
system as opposed to extending a rail
line from the city center but we
wouldn't have known that have we not
engage people and then for architectural
project we started to design a new kind
of building that would allow this
flexibility within the building so
people could add on rooms when their
relatives came to live with them for a
while or they could rent a room out to
someone else if they needed to make
extra cash so it was an idea about you
know doing a building that would support
this community in Cicero another thing
that we do in our practice which I think
everybody should do is it's just makeup
projects you know sometimes clients
don't walk in through the door with the
project that you want to think about and
and so what we've been doing over over
the years is as as a problem begins to
show itself we might make that problem a
project for ourselves in this case we we
the project really ended up being a book
and a series of steps that the city
could take to improve its waterways and
and it came about from a number of
sessions we had been doing on the
ecology around the river and the
post-industrial river again we we met
with a lot of people that were using the
river and and found out that even though
is an incredibly dirty river with with
raw sewage being ejected right into it
there's still a lot of people in the
public that that use the river and so we
interviewed them
and we also figured out what the
engineering problems were in terms of
this way waste treating the the river
like a waste sewage canal we also had
you know flooding basements with with
increased severe storms through climate
change we have a this carp species
that's coming up the Mississippi
threatening to get into the Great Lakes
so is another huge environmental issue
the bad water quality but then the south
of this great potential of space that
that could be used that is no longer
being used for its industrial purposes
so so we thought this was like a perfect
the ingredients that make a really
interesting project and so we went ahead
and made this book the design that
really came out of the book was these
steps that we recommended for Chicago to
renew the waterway and I should say to
that we also took this problem to some
students at Harvard Graduate School
design and they came up with solutions
to these incredibly difficult problems
as well so we we had a whole slate of
solutions and that we displayed in in
the book and I should say that number
the step number this one here step
number one was really about increasing
the public's access to this waterway
even though it is dirty and it is like
you don't want to ingest this water I
tell you but but the idea that giving
people more access to it would create
more stewards for this river and then
you know ultimately improve its quality
so that was one of our recommendations
and what was really interesting in as
this book came out and there was some
positive movement on the policies about
the river like that the Metropolitan
Water Reclamation District would have to
finally disinfect it's sewage before
putting it into the river and some other
things and I'm not saying it's because
of the book but the book was timed to be
released you know we collaborated with
the NRDC natural resource defense
counsel and we timed it to release a
prior to these policy change
opportunities but step number one
suddenly became a real a real project
for us as our city got new leadership
and they were looking for ways to
increase access to this river we ended
up being kind of the experts at that and
it wasn't you know we didn't even know
there was a boathouse project in the
works but but it turned out that this
was one of the ways that the city and
the park district were thinking of
giving people access to turn this more
this dirty river into a recreational
frontier um and then you know I'll just
tell you quick things about the design
we we really didn't have a lot of time
we wanted to get this project going they
told us they wanted it open in one year
and and again it becomes you know it's
for the for the city it is it's kind of
like helping them with their identity
what will the city become so so we
relied on some of our past knowledge of
this is a muybridge photos of rowing
that around turn a century and we also
made some models of rowing because this
is the positions of an or during you
know one cycle and and start to study
those things and we ended up turning
that that movement into the roof form
for the building and and the benefits of
that were to bring light into the into
the shelter I think we we are using like
sixty five percent less energy than most
buildings the typical building in the
city you can see these Clara stories
they allow the Sun to come in and warm
the slab so we didn't actually have to
use mechanical systems in this space
this is this is the boathouse with the
team using it and we also use very
straight and rectilinear elements to
build the roof so there's no curved
element
but altogether because of the the change
in position just like with the or we got
this beautiful warped surface for the
ceiling there's a retro tank in there
for kids to exercise and in the winter
months that like now because it's
impossible to go into the river but it's
really become this hub in the community
and they do a lot of programs with vets
and kids from all over city that learned
to row so this is really a kind of a
very strong community building project
that came out of the project that we
made up which was the reverse effect
book as another technique I think for
for designers is really too and in our
office is extremely research focus
because we work on these different
projects that are completely unique they
might have a different program they
might have different client and a
different site in a different part of
the world we have to really start to
understand get our head around the
project so we create a bibliography for
every project and what that does is it
allows people who join on the team later
because sometimes the project might take
five six years they can always go back
to that resource the bibliography which
constantly grows throughout that the
course of the project and they can get
access to the initial materials that
made us inspired in the first place and
so in a way i call it just like
developing a fluency with in our office
but also a lot of the times the books
are recommended by our clients and and
we we start to learn how to speak their
language and and then every single every
single projects like learning a new
language one project i wanted to go into
kind of like the ways the techniques
that we've been using for co-creation as
well with our projects bringing in that
expertise from from outside one of the
projects is called northerly island it's
a 90 acre park on on the shores of Lake
Michigan it was
warmer air port and the airport was was
pulled out and then we won a competition
we're together with landscape
engineering firm to redesign this
project so because of such a public
space you know before it was a kind of a
private Airport and we're turning this
into a public space we really wanted to
get input from stakeholders so one of
the techniques that we use was doing
sure ettes which are work sessions with
with various people with different stake
in the project and we broke up into
teams and each team had designers on
them and we developed about four schemes
together with members of the public to
to discuss and talk about and that
really works well with public projects
very necessary actually what we ended up
designing was a place that would be
almost like an outpost to the various
museums nearby in the museum campus so
we had like a places for bird-watching
places for fish to spawn that the
correspond to the shedd aquarium and
also stargazing and things like that
that kind of related to the Adler
Planetarium and of course the field
museum and then many different
activities that that at one hand help
fund the whole project but on the other
hand really get at that that that core
belief of a bringing nature into the
city and and increasing biodiversity and
then letting that be a learning tool for
kids so they're going to have camping
there for inner-city kids that can come
right out in the city and in camp
overnight we're going to have like a
sunken ship that we're going to buy
online and sink down in there for a few
fish that's actually a kind of a great
place for fish to spawn and lots of
activities as well one other way that
we've been doing it's almost like you
have to design the tool to for them to
enable your your partner your client to
help to be able to be a designer because
maybe many people aren't trained as
designer this was a renovation and a new
office for the headquarters
for the national resource defense
counsel and they're a bunch of attorneys
that usually had their offices closed in
with doors and and because we were going
for a really great you know
sustainability rating a leed platinum
and also Living Building Challenge which
is really hard to get we needed to get
everyone out of their offices and out
into an open floor so we realized that
this was going to be very hard for the
attorneys to to do and they knew it was
going to be hard and so we didn't want
to be the bad guy that said hey you guys
don't get in office anymore so we
brought a tool to them to use which was
basically just this game like map and we
cut out workstations of different sizes
and then we literally let them arrange
them in the way that they wanted to and
and what was really interesting about
the exercises they started to understand
the trade-offs and the things that they
were going to the benefits these are
like the different ones we photographed
these at the end the different ones that
that they really came up with so it was
a kind of a discovery process and it
really helped to facilitate and move the
project forward and in a way that was
beneficial to them and to us another
thing is just iterating you know that
these are models many different models
that we created for a creative director
for a theater who was very concerned
about that the seating and the intimacy
of the theater and went over just you
know another thing is just making making
lots of models that people can relate to
and connect to we designed the ad to
Story Tower in Chicago called aqua and
and you know when I got into tall
buildings it was really a very different
it's a different kind of design process
very different than what we had done
with cultural institutions and we were
excited about the idea of increasing the
density and the footprint in the city
but one of the challenges from a design
standpoint it was
you know how do you know what something
is going to look like that's bet far
away from the ground so many times we're
picking out materials for buildings you
can you can kind of mock up things and
prototype things but with something that
large we had to come up with creative
ways to prototype this project one of
the things that we did early on was just
model making not only the building
itself but everything around it way
around it to find out you know its
relationship to its surroundings in its
sight lines as we got more into it you
know we really got into working with the
builders and the and the developer about
the means and methods that the the way
that the curvilinear floor slabs would
be made because every single floor slab
is different to create that kind of wave
effect and in order to do that quickly
without using lots of foam and bad
materials we found a steel piece the
right thickness that could be reused
over and over on every floor but trial
and error with these kinds of full-scale
mock-ups I mean again as well you know
with before building that doing a wind
tunnel test this is up in Canada there's
a giant a facility where you can really
start to see what the effects of the
wind tunnel are and what was really
exciting to find out in our design
process was that by varying the floor
slabs slightly every single floor slab
we were able to improve the quality of
the space in the outdoor so in other
words it reduces the wind pressure so
people can use their terraces more more
days during the year even though it's
freezing Chicago with everybody likes
get outside when it's nice and it's also
kind of a it gave us this social
connection between neighbors that you
normally don't get in a high-rise so
people can see each other and you know
people started evidently dating and
things like that um we have a material
testing one of the things that you can't
get wrong unlike product testing in
architecture you only have one shot to
you know
do it so you really got to get the the
prototyping as close to the actual as
possible but in our experimentation and
where we're trying to think about
materials in different ways we do
projects that are smaller and scale like
exhibitions or I told you about the
moment exhibition or this one is at the
National the National Building Museum
where we were testing a material taking
its to its limit we wanted to see how
thin the marble could be and if it could
work in tension I wouldn't do that with
a building but it with an exhibition it
was really exciting we used a lot of
different technical discoveries and
trial and error to get it to this this
place where something like 650 pieces of
3h in stone hanging from the ceiling of
the museum without any structural
support or frame again we're working
testing the materials in the engineering
lab pulling it apart testing different
connections I think there is really a
connection between how we innovate with
material and how we innovate on the
scale of City and trying to connect
those two ends of the spectrum another
way is using data we've collaborate with
data analytics firms too especially for
visitor serving organizations so that
that we can kind of test our scenarios
before going out and building it all the
way out and then finally I think with
with these ideas about creativity one of
one of the things we've learned along
the way is that the client might not
always come to you with with the precise
question that the project needs to
answer they know they might know they
need a building and they know they need
something iconic or they know that they
need something that that really is
functional but but framing the issue
critically thinking about the issue is
is really an important part of design so
one of the things I'm really excited
about right now is working with the
National Aquarium and
Baltimore where they are trying to go
from being a kind of visitor serving
more entertainment venue to being more
of a conservation organization that uses
their aquarium to help to help emphasize
their message and in doing that really
thinking about the ocean in many
different facets has been really
exciting for us you can see there's a
little bit of a water theme that goes
through our work but water and
environment and how those intersect with
people and cities is really the core and
then I thought I'd talk just at the end
about the difficulties that that we've
had you know in terms of growing the
company you know some people were asking
me like how big do you want to be how
big do you want your company to be and
as we got bigger and bigger projects
that those are the question and I
realized finally like that is not a
question that I really feel like is the
question I need to answer the question I
need to answer is how to we want to we
want to do more impactful work we want
to do more projects that are going to
change how we think about the
environment so the question is really
how to grow it so that we're able to do
that but to keep the things that we feel
we are really good at and to keep me the
creativity like a small firm creativity
even though we're growing to a bigger
structure so it was really a kind of a
challenge that we've been working on
over the last couple years and we had
this very collegial atmosphere in our
office um we really share information
there's no hoarding of information we
are we like each other we we really get
excited about ideas and so with more and
more people how do you maintain that I
mean people we do a lot of things like
you know we spend a lot of time there so
you know we do things like these pumpkin
carvings and many
other things camp things like that but
what I realized recently is you know the
growth of us what like this is all of
the firm's all the architecture firms
that are in the American Institute of
Architects there's about 17,500 firms
twenty-six percent of them are sole
practitioners like one person I started
out that way to I was one person when I
started the firm but we stayed in i
guess like I was there for about a year
at one person and then we moved into
this area which 71 percent of firms are
only two to 49 people so if they're
relatively small and I think they're
most of them are on the smaller end of
that now we're about 80 people and so
we're like moved into this the upper to
three percent there's only there's only
two percent of firms that are over 50
and less than hundred there's only one
percent of the firm's that are over a
hundred so so it's it's it's very
interesting and it's also so we're like
seeing that is really giving us insight
as to what our potential could be now
that as we shift into this other area by
the way about a third of all of the
architecture graduates are employed in
that from the top three percent of of
the firm's of the large firms so one
thing we've been doing we continue we
grew our camp we go to camp every year
and the creativity camp and we expanded
it and it's still accommodating us at 80
and we do different activities and
different classes together we try to
have fun together but at the same time
we did have to put structure in place
and so you know this was really about
trying to figure out how people could
you know be mentored and grow within the
firm but it really didn't feel like us
you know I was like oh suddenly we have
this pyramid and this hierarchy and and
how what do we really want that to be so
we we spent a long time working on that
we
we have a diagram that represents our
project orientation so when we work on a
project the project is in the middle and
we're all around it but this one really
just wasn't sitting well for us and so
one day as we were just working on this
filling it out I noticed that it
actually looked better like this and and
and that was a kind of an aha moment
because for us it really is about
support and growth this is almost like a
tree and where the ideas are coming in
and they are the nutrients and and
they're going out and branching up in
each branch with people that have been
there longer can support and mentor
people that are coming in that are new
up at the top and the people that are
new and up at the top have a chance to
becoming a branch and becoming a tree so
I think the lesson here is just that
even when you have to change your
organization to accommodate something
like growth you can still own it you can
still own you know that growth and make
it be what you want it to be you can
design it and so now our latest
iteration is is really going to be
something more like this that we're
working on which is the same thing only
slightly curvier so with that I want to
thank you and let you take questions
oh okay sitting on oxy space is really
important to you can you describe the
space that you've created in your own
firm with this many people to foster
this type of creativity and innovation
okay the question is really about space
and what kind of space are we actually
in what kind of space do we inhabit to
foster creativity and and I think it's a
great question it's it's something that
we evolved over time we kind of grew
into our space we started in in a small
end of the office and then and in the
same floor there was a poet society and
there was a communist bookstore and and
there was a ambulance chasing lawyer as
well and so but after we started to grow
and get space as they moved out we took
over the whole floor and we what we did
was we used all the materials that were
already there so starting with what's
there these incredible doors that look
like a detective agency door and we made
walls out of those and we made different
rooms for collaboration with different
atmospheres so there's a silver room in
orange room a white room a broom on a
garden a garden space and and the teams
move in and out of those spaces to
collaborate so but as we've grown we've
you know we're starting to fill in every
single space we've we've actually got a
new building that we're going to be
moving into in the summer and so we've
had the opportunity to actually plan
from scratch what our space will be like
and so what we were decided to do is you
need to plan in more mobility in which
has not been done yet for architects
we're usually stuck to our desks and
because we have a lot of stuff but we're
we're devising ways to liberate people
from their desks and be able to you know
use more mobility for collaboration and
many different even more atmospheres
throughout the office oh yes
listen don't pee on so I'm work i'm
originally from china and our cities are
growing very fast and sold them as 20
years a lot of skyscrapers and quality
today my son publicly that's what is
going on so there are probably more
skyscrapers under construction that
accessory so i'm wondering those people
became more isolated their health and
thinking on fighting on these huge
beauties the sense of culturing
community and start you require kind of
cities from the weather it ok so just
quickly summarizing question insights
about high density tall buildings in big
cities how to make those even more more
human and with the loss of community
that happens when when smaller scale
buildings get replaced by tall buildings
yeah yeah yeah yes right and so we
thought a lot about that too when i
first got the commission for the aqua
tower and we had never done at our
before and so but i was really excited
to take that on the condition in in a
city like Chicago which will kind of
like maybe like a post-industrial city
where people are moving out of the city
it had a different significance there so
the people that would live there we
found out where people who are maybe
their kids went away to school they
might be coming back downtown for
culture a lot of graduate students that
live there and people that work nearby
in the in the loop so it was a little
bit different situation but we still
felt that the you know there was
something that that bothered all of us
because we at our office we like to go
outside and step outside in the balcony
and and socialize we felt like there's
an opportunity to make a more social
tall building and so we we gravitated
toward what the terrorists could do so
that you could step out
side and be you know part of the
building and part of the city at the
same time and also have these views to
other people obliquely could maybe
similar to like what it would be like to
see someone across the yard and across
the fence near our yard instead of going
for this total privacy which is you know
what the pressure is to do and then you
know you could see someone without
having the five minutes of going down
the elevator and going outside so there
was that and also social space on top of
the podium part of the building and the
innovation there i think was just like
using convincing everyone that it would
be to everyone's benefit if we didn't
separate the people who own apartment or
rent apartments from the people who own
their condominiums from the hotel
there's three different uses in there so
we combined all of those into the
amenities that are on the roof of the
podium and that has been extremely
successful because you know people
really meet their neighbors and so
there's a lot of social space within the
building so I think that's important to
consider in each place you know it's
going to be specific like what were
people doing before for community and
how can that be translated into this
vertical but the importance of going
vertical is really I think mostly about
reducing that carbon footprint you know
making making cities more dense but at
the same time making them livable you
know and improving quality of life
instead of sprawling out you know across
the countryside which is what has been
going on here so thank you you mentioned
uh I guess architects really were kind
of jack of all trades that slowly
increasing
there's more specialization like
specialized the the trend in
architecture with building information
modeling seems to be that in order to
effectively use that you kind of need to
bring those parties together in our
descendants human firms are half
structuring will know if I think to
forcibly back including more design how
do you see the image you changing in
light of what's happening
technologically and help that's a great
question how's the industry changing
with respect to the specialization given
the building information modeling
software that we're using now as a
platform it's a very positive
development and the opportunity to have
everybody working on the same model is a
great it's a great way to bring everyone
together it seems so obvious but it just
hadn't happened until now you know and
and even now sometimes certain parties
are not brought into the model or don't
want to be part of it like oftentimes
the Builder isn't up to that yet so a
lot of the knowledge that's built into
the model doesn't you know get
distributed so but it's a great it's a
great way to start merging them bridging
those gaps between the different
specialists I don't think the
specialists are going away but I do
think that the the we all will know more
about each other's work and that will
improve everybody's work and and I do
see blurring of boundaries you know in
our firm but in other firms to where you
you start to you know get closer to one
of those other professions and and start
to maybe do something that would have
been in their territory and they might
do something that would have been in
your territory so but the model is a
great tool to bring everyone and get
them all focused on on the building as
opposed to many of the other things that
go on in collaborations so the green
yeah I'm curious how you divide your
personal time between like eating with
clients building relationships and do
actual architecture and designing
buildings mm-hmm personal time now yeah
it I think it's a very good question so
you know that's evolved a little bit too
but still at this point in the office
I'm still involved in all the projects
and and what we've done in our structure
is bring up more design principles that
are almost like you know double gangers
and we can we can communicate very
fluidly and there you know excellent
designers and they've been with us a
long time so there's there's a kind of
you know ability to spread it out a
little bit more often times I'll get
really involved in a certain phase and
then my involvement will be you know
more or less frequent and other phases
and and maybe get back frequent again
during construction things like that so
still trying to manage that and there
isn't a lot of like personal you know
personal time there's it's a lot of I do
what I love to do and I do it all the
time so and and I think a lot of us feel
like that we have to make ourselves you
know take breaks and things like that it
that's a nice thing about a creative
profession or occupation is like you
actually like doing it so much you do
and the other thing I would mention to
on your question is just that we've
brought in people to we've started to
bring in people that can do take things
off of my plate that I used to have to
do so when I first started the company I
was doing the quickbooks and doing the
time you know and doing the I was the
tech person setting up the network and
you know we would have 15 people
suddenly go down on their computers and
I would be it no media get up I wouldn't
let anyone touch it because I built it
so in but I got over that and uh and and
now you know there's somebody who cares
about that as much
I did at one point and as well as
financial things and human resource
things and things that so that's
actually helped liberate my time and
it's also made us a stronger
organization um okay design the word
structure little outdated since you
skilled up yeah what was another thing I
was really how kid is killing up from
just yourself to 78 people to Europe
right now I think the probably the
hardest time was when we were about you
know 10 people that that's when you
really are doing every single thing and
so as soon as the private what helped us
was getting a mix of projects some
larger and some you know the small ones
sometimes take as many people to do a
small project as it does to do a large
project but you don't want to give up
the small project because sometimes are
really important to your mission or to
you know your creative spirit so so
getting a balance of project was you
know getting that first big project
because convincing people that you can
do it you know I I feel like some help
my time is but convincing people we can
do it and so so once you get that
balance then then there's more cushion
to be able to take on projects that
might not be profitable or they might be
labor-intensive or doing something like
the book which was you know there's no
paying project there's no paying client
for that so it's it's hard to get the
right balance and actually it's still
hot it's still hard because you might
have some very large projects all at
once and then you need that you're
looking for that project that you really
you know is going to make everything
come together and and other times you
have to have a bunch of small projects
and they take up all the people and
there's not any profit to cushion
everything so so that is still that's
always the hard part about architecture
that's designs okay see you now yeah
green and sustainability that's all I'm
good but the end of the day architecture
firms have to make money curious for a
medium-sized architecture for life
yourself you articulate the business
case of articulating the building case
for designing a green building from the
architects standpoint or from the owner
clients from the architects standpoint
you know it's it's been I guess the
business case is that we want to be the
best at what we do and so to master that
is putting us into a category of best
and so doing something like the NRDC
where was the first time it was a living
building challenge indeed took us a lot
more time to do that to figure it out
but achieving it then put us just in a
category that it can't be we are the
only ones that have done that on a
commercial renovation and that's what we
believe in so i think it's it's a matter
of being a excellent the excellence case
i guess but it's also a benefit
obviously for all of our clients because
they will see the productivity increase
in their own work spaces and and all the
things the benefits that come with like
a healthy living environment like that
that's kind of the way we've been
looking at it I'm gonna go over there
first yep can't buy your business
growing is as that's happened I'm sure
you're now turning away opportunities
and clients projects how do you
determine
projects you're going to take which ones
you are what are some of the qualifiers
but yeah ok so we question is really a
question is really about how do you
decide what projects to to take or turn
away at this point and it's true that we
do have to make those decisions and we
we meet every week on our projects the
opportunities that come through the door
and if they meet our you know our
philosophical criteria if the if the if
the client or the partner you know that
we will be working with is impressive in
their you know their philosophy and if
we also take something if we think that
we can really if it's complex and we
think that we can actually make it
different you know make a difference and
then yeah like sometimes it's really
just the city or the place like we've
always wanted to do a project in that
city so you know those sometimes
intangible things that help you decide
and there are times when you have to
turn away something you really want to
do just because you've got to make sure
that you have the capacity to do the
projects well so um yeah that that's
become a little bit easier but at first
is very hard to turn away something
after all the years spent you know you
know scraping by and getting projects by
serially one by one yes understanding
those
her difficult during the Great Recession
for parking checker how did you been how
did we manage during the Great Recession
starting in two thousand eight well um
yes we basically we had this really
great mix of projects we never went went
you there was a big boom with
residential products like after aqua and
it was it was built you know was done
right before the recession just got in
under the wire but there before that a
lot of architects had had turned their
practices to towards solely doing those
because they're very profitable and they
it was a boom and but but I think
focusing on that one type of project led
a lot of firms to actually have to close
their doors but we had just a really
good mix of not we made a lot less money
after 2008 for just you know a number of
years and but the great news was we
didn't have to lay anyone off we kept
her size solid we had a little bit of
natural attrition there but but kept
salad and then we use that time to
retool some of our things like improving
our BIM system software knowledge and
and we did a lot of planning also like
planning for growth which was good
because it took us a long time to figure
out how we wanted to grow we spend a lot
of time thinking about them we had
different models all of our planning for
growth we did with our office so it
wasn't like a group of the leadership
thinking of it and coming and giving it
we had you know we had sessions where we
would come up with different models from
everybody from the newest person and and
we we tried went out for a while didn't
quite work and then we finally you know
like I said it made it our own and so
we've managed through that period I'm
sure you'll agree this was totally
inspirational please join me and thank
you to the gang
you